When I was younger, I was a musician...
...and at some point, my mother became a little bit desperate and said,...
"Well, it's probably time for you to find a proper job."
And she saw this advertising for a position at Hertz,...
...which I applied for in the middle of August when I was on the beach...
...and surprisingly, I'd been hired by Hertz.
I was taking the reservations, washing the cars.
Now I'm running Hertz International,...
...which is essentially everything outside the American continent...
...which we really animate and run from here, from this place.
And like a lot of American companies,...
...they elected to locate the international head office in the UK.
I think the UK has a lot of strength which is appealing to companies.
One of course, is the language.
But also much more easily here in the UK than in other places,...
...you find an accountant, we call them CPA,...
...so we have the knowledge of American accounting rules.
Britain is also what we call an important source market...
...and I mean by this that the British people travel a lot outside of the UK.
People like to discover different regions...
...so, it's an important source of business for us.
I think it is a country where retail is almost like an art and a science at the same time.
I find UK people very pragmatic,...
...very much looking forward to this new world which is moving so fast.
They are very Internet savvy.
That makes the UK really attractive...
...because you can apply what you do and what you learn in the UK to other geographies.